on
va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à mes
côtés marie roger biloa bonjour vous
diriger le groupe africain international
merci d'être avec nous comme chaque
mardi et face à vous gauthier rybinski
la rédaction de france 24 jean gauthier
toujours vraies avancées ou fausses
concessions volodymyr zelensky se dit
prêt à parler de tout avec vladimir
poutine mais avec lui seul comprenez
bien une rencontre directe entre les
deux hommes dans laquelle ils compris
les statuts de la crimée et du donbass
pourrait être sur la table à condition
que le cren bénéficie de garanties de
sécurité
des compromis donc qu'il soumettrait le
cas échéant à référendum écoutez le
président ukrainien c'était en réponse à
notre consoeur de france télévisions
agnès vahramian au nom du groupement des
médias audiovisuels publics européens
membres de l'eurovision
les questions de garanties de sécurité
aussi pour nous allons devoir parler des
modifications constitutionnelles
modification de la cie vous nous
en parler dans tous les cas ce sera
décidé non pas seulement par le
président mais c'est là que je joue ce
sera décidé par le parlement et par les
ports ukrainiens toute façon on peut pas
faire un an
hao référendum au référendum c'est le
peuple qui devra dire sont moins tenait
sa réponse à tel ou tel format de
compromis il ya de la part de deux
élèves ce qui est une réelle avancée
gauthier
dans sa situation
généralement c'est quand on est en
position de force qu'on peut faire des
propositions là étant là où il est c'est
à dire il y avait dans une situation
militaire difficile mais qui en même
temps n'est pas catastrophique
contamment a secoué le croient ils
chipent aux quelque sorte aux russes le
magistère de l'initiative et ce faisant
il l'est au fond c'est peut-être plus
dans la manière dont il les coins ce que
par la proposition qu'il fait il les
coince de deux façons en parlant du dawn
ba 110 ans au fond il semble que ça soit
ça qui vous gratouille qui vous démange
la question du dôme base et des
russophones et bien très bien on met la
chose sur la table et on en discute les
accords de minsk avait eu pour objectif
de régler cette question elle n'avait
pas été réglée d'ailleurs parce que les
ukrainiens n'ont pas respecté ces
accords de minsk mais parce que de
l'autre côté aussi la prétention de ces
et république autoproclamée du donbass
était d'avoir un droit de regard sur la
politique internationale ukrainienne
vous pensez si c'était acceptable donc
il remet la question disons très bien
moi j'en parle premier poids deuxième
point encore plus intéressant il dit il
y aura un référendum
quelques avancées que ce soit puisse
être trouvée il y aura un référendum ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que vous
russe qui prétendait que notre
gouvernement est un gouvernement de
nazis eh bien nous allons voir ça on va
en quelque sorte déconnecter le
gouvernement et demandé à tous les
ukrainiens de ce but se prononcer donc
c'est une manière aussi de les coincer
un petit détail qui est quand même aussi
intéressant en politique interne
ukrainienne 6 helens qui se permet de
dire ça c'est qu'il a une quasi
certitude de maîtriser l'électorat
ukrainien et y compris les ultra
nationalistes dont on parle beaucoup et
qui sont une pierre d'achoppement ou en
tout cas un argument de propagande dans
la bouche de poutine marie roger biloa
des des garanties de sécurité dans la
bouche de zelensky ça veut dire la
capacité de conclure des accords de
défense bilatéraux avec des puissances
occidentales
à défaut de pouvoir intégrer l'otan
cette proposition de zielinski vous
semble-t-elle acceptable d'un point de
vue russe
alors c'est lens qui a sans doute du
pouvoir sur sa population parce que ils
sont tous
contre cette invasion russe ils sont
patriotes nationalistes et sert à ça
c'est un bloc qu'on a vu jusqu'à
maintenant mais ça s'arrête là il n'a
pas beaucoup de pouvoir et ce qui se
passe à qui a même beaucoup de pouvoir
vis-à-vis de la russie
actuellement maintenant je crois qu'il
est temps de penser sérieusement
solution parce que jusqu'à maintenant ce
qu'on a vu c'est les le monde occidental
peut parler comme ça qui choqués
évidemment par cette agression russe
décide de prendre des sanctions alors
les sanctions quand on les prend elle
vise à quoi n'ont pas arrêté la galère
mais affaiblir l'économie russe or ce
qu'il faut maintenant c'est arrêter la
guerre et on ne voit pas
les mesures ou les démarches réellement
qui sont faites du point de vue de la
diplomatie ce conte par l'ascension
encore sanctions l'union européenne se
réunissaient pour l'essentiel pour de
nouvelles sanctions que justement
l'excès ya ces ouvriers ont semble-t-il
de volodine zelensky à destination de
moscou alors un compromis acceptable
pour la russie alors cesser cette
ouverture à mon avis arrive un moment où
chacun réalise que personne peut gagner
la guerre zola ce qui peut pas la gagner
on a dit beaucoup qu'ils étaient très
brave et courageux certes mais ça savent
ça flatte un peu les occidentaux qui se
disent il résiste bien mais résiste quoi
vis-à-vis de la russie si tout ce qui
peut arriver c'est que la russie détruit
complètement l'ukraine et je crois que
ça c'est pas le but souhaité alors
aujourd'hui ce qui est important à mon
avis c'est que on regarde qu'eux on a
bien parlé un petit peu des causes mais
il faut maintenant publiquement
reconnaître un peu les responsabilités
des uns et les autres là l'europe n'a
pas été que négatives vis-à-vis de la
russie c'est au contraire le l'amérique
les états unis qui ont une position
jusqu'au-boutiste
les européens ont toujours essayé
d'avoir des dialogues qu'on a vues macro
et qui a accueilli
poutine parions 2 milliards même là
aujourd'hui on critique l'allemagne
d'être très dépendants des russes mais
c'est parce qu'il est voulait les
engagés ils ont toujours voulu il se
rapprocher de poutine de la russie et
cetera tous les pays européens n'ont pas
le même discours et donc ceux qui ont
exacerbé la situation c'est surtout les
américains qui a déjà je crois que
c'était un
en 2008 en avril avec harris 10 annonce
que la la géorgie et l'ukraine vont être
de devenir des membres de l'otan savait
beaucoup énervé il allait signer
exactement mais ce n'est pas ça ne
justifie pas l'invasion du jcp non pas
du tout mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que il faudrait maintenant que les
européens qui ont plus de compréhension
pour la question russes parlent aux
américains et 10 nous sommes dans le
temps ensemble puisque pas existe mais
nous devons maintenant
prendre en compte les intérêts des uns
et des autres et voir ce qui peut
réellement arrêter la guerre qu'elles
n'ont pas toujours être dans l'escaladé
militaire on parle maintenant de bombes
de d'armes chimiques etc mais de quoi
qu'on prend la mauvaise voie gauthier à
anata un interlocuteur plus acceptable
pour la russie l'europe que jusqu'à
présent moscou a toujours écarté à des
discussions bilatérales que souhaite
justement vladimir poutine avec les
états unis que souhaiter jusqu'à présent
mais bien moins que les états unis oui
d'abord pour des raisons de forme à 1 et
2 d'épaisseur l'adversaire américains
des russes est celui qui a le mot qui à
dire son mot qui donne le la de l'action
occidentale et puis n'oublions pas aussi
que dans l'esprit 2e poutine et de son
cercle l'europe est considérée comme
étant un ramassis de décadent 1 c'est à
dire que la liberté tant qu'aide demande
est telle qu'elle est conçue en europe
est un signe de décadence
l'europe c'est aussi ce qui légalise le
mariage homosexuel et c'est dans
l'esprit de poutine c'est ça donc il est
effectivement l'europe est éliminé même
si on a vu qu emmanuel macron semble
avoir maintenu un rapport privilégié
avec
autant d hier soir pendant le week-end
et puis de toute manière alors
effectivement et pour eux brute prendre
simplement votre question d'une phrase
pourquoi vladimir poutine tout d'un coup
se tourneraient t-il vers l'europe alors
qu'il a précisément par nécessité par
nécessité peut-être mais en tout cas oui
en tout cas la difficulté de l'armée
russe a revendiqué des gains
significatifs sur le terreau alimenté
les spéculations pour le pentagone le
rapport de force serait même en train de
s'inverser sur le terrain comme bien le
dire le porte parole du pentagone indue
du ministère du secrétariat américain à
la défense john kirby sur cnn je le cite
vous le voyez les militaires ukrainiens
sont désormais dans certaines situations
à l'offensive ils pourchassent les
russes et les repoussant dehors des
zones où les russes étaient par le passé
les forces russes ne conduisent pas
leurs opérations avec la coordination
qu'on aurait pu attendre une armée
moderne gauthier ça correspond à ce
qu'on observe sur le terrain ça oui
c'est la propagande alors j'allais vous
dire une réponse de normand peut-être
bien qu'oui ptêt ben qu'non ou les deux
mais il ya effectivement des
observations très clair sur le retrait
le retrait c'est à dire forcée d'un
certain nombre de deux détachements
russe ça c'est tout à fait clair pour
une raison qui est simple et là aussi on
pourrait gloser indéfiniment sur
l'opportunité de mener une invasion à
cette époque mais on a bien dit que les
terrains étaient extrêmement boueux et
gras c'est à dire que les blindés russes
6 en faire aussi six ans les orbes et
que de ce fait l'un saigne conséquences
très simple c'est que les blindés russes
sont obligés d'emprunter des routes
traditionnelles et que de ce fait là ils
sont beaucoup plus vulnérables
vulnérables parce que non seulement sur
cette route ils sont à portée de tir de
ceux qui se placerait mais aussi pour
une raison très simple c'est que quand
vous faites ce genre de cheminement vous
êtes obligés de descendre des blindés
pour protéger au véhicule et qui dit je
descends du blindé pour protéger mon
vécu dit je ne combat pas pendant ce
temps là alors si on ajoute à cela les
communications que l'on arrive aussi à
capter entre soldats russes qui font
état de leur désarroi
de leur désespoir parfois même du manque
de nourriture puisque certains certaines
colonnes ont été scindés en plusieurs
morceaux et que la l'intendance la
cantine pour être vus n'arrive pas c'est
aussi cela d'une certaine manière on
peut même évaluer la chose sur le fait
que s'il y avait un des frappes très
très précis sur les l'intendance russe
ça serait un moyen peut-être de hâter la
fin de la guerre ça pourrait inciter les
russes à saisir la main tendue de deux
élèves qui est les russes attendent de
vraies signe parce que je crois que
c'est ils voient que cette guerre est
difficile pour eux et pensé que ce
serait plus rapide
mais je crois que c'est une illusion que
deux c'est une erreur de maintenir cette
illusion que les
craintes gagner la guerre ne peut pas
gagner la guerre elle peut retarder son
dénouement elle peut mais les américains
cette déclaration quand même qu'ils sont
toujours dans le rôle des incendiaires
et vous allez gagner vous allez gagner
quoi que le pays soit entièrement
détruit rasé ils sont très loin eux ils
n'ont pas trop de problème avec ça il
sait l'europe va être très déstabilisés
par cette guerre du elle n'est pas là
pour durer et je crois que la nature des
sanctions même qu'on a prises qui sont
extrêmement lourdes impose que ce soit
rapide est bref et on ne peut pas juste
se dire vous allez gagner on va rien
gagner si on n'arrive pas rapidement à
trouver des sous sur une solution
vraiment diplomatique et de faire des
propositions car elle voit en direct à
poutine en tout cas
zelensky invité à s'exprimer par vidéo
conférence au sommet de l'otan ce jeudi
alors oui s'exprime voilà il ya beaucoup
de compassion mais il faut aussi les
raisonner je crois que les russes les
pays de l'est ont une relation c'est de
l'art il avait clarifié la présence de
l'otan en europe pour clarifier mais
aussi il faut il faut modérer tempéré
linski et les pays de l'est mais quand
il joue un homme extrêmement 1-2 jantes
avec avec la ligne à poutine deux ou
trois phrases de deux trois phrases
imaginons simplement que depuis
1990 ou à l'orée des années 2000 la
russie soit devenue un pays démocratique
alors vous allez me dire c'est du rail
l'état imaginons cela prenons le comme
une hypothèse pas une pas un des motifs
qui aujourd'hui président à l'amener de
cette invasion et de cette guerre
n'aurait résister il n'y aurait pas de
guerre la housse est capital c'est que
c'est un dictateur fondamentalement qui
mène une guerre alors je suis d'accord
avec vous il ya peu de cette déraison il
y à des circonstances qui ont été mal
mal tourné des tournantes qui ont été
mal abordé très bien mais le fond du
fond c'est que c'est une agression menée
par un dictateur c'est le mans qui vit
est entièrement nier les tentatives d'un
pays comme l'ukraine qui essaye de se
sortir de son giron certainement mais
alors comment sortent ça bien sûr
vladimir poutine est 100% responsable de
la guerre je pense que un jour ou
l'autre il va payer d'une manière ou
d'une autre mais le problème aujourd'hui
c'est les ukrainiens est ce qu'on a au
détriment un pays c'est l'europe est ce
que l'europe doit être totalement
déstabilisé par cette guerre qui va
risquent d'être plus longs est-ce qu'on
va accepter qu'on s'installe dans une
guerre interminable voilà les questions
qu'il faut se poser pour dépassionner le
débat il faut il faut sortir des
passionnés oui c'est très difficile
c'est aujourd'hui en tout cas la journée
mondiale de l'eau thème de cette 22e
édition préserver les ressources en eau
souterraine c'est la moitié à la
consommation totale d'eau potable sur la
planète un potentiel les eaux
souterraines encore inexplorés
dans certaines régions du monde comme en
afrique subsaharienne mari roger oui
l'afrique sub la reine en particulier au
sahel a perdu depuis 2000 plus de 40 %
de son potentiel de ses ressources en
eau et il ya des chercheurs qui parle de
la diagonale de la soif qui part de
tanger passe par le sahel traverse le
moyen-orient jusqu'à à la chine du
nord-est donc c'est quand même beaucoup
de pays et en afrique il y avait d'un
côté ça tombe bien il y avait sept cette
semaine le sommet mondial de l'eau à à
dakar où le présent macky sall a
justement demandé que ce soit au coeur
de l'agenda ce mal avec un clin d'oeil à
ce qui se passe évidemment la guerre en
ukraine qui nous occupe tous mais qu'il
faut pas oublier tous les problèmes et
actuellement on a
la libye là pardon là
l'ethiopie qui étant en conflit
maintenant avec l'erythrée qu'une partie
de l'ethiopie
est dans une situation extrêmement
critique et de conflits aussi à j'allais
dire de basse intensité c'est pour ce à
quoi on parle pas beaucoup mais c'est
pas moins grave avec l'egypte parce que
à cause d'un barrage
que l'ethiopie a construite sur le le
nil bleu qui est un des affluents du nil
et et parce qu'ils veulent la lecture
puis voulons remplir ce barrage et se
heurte à l'opposition de l'egypte alors
on a eu beaucoup peur que cela décolle
dégénère en guerre et ça c'est toujours
latent ne sais pas jusqu'où ça ira mais
les problèmes d'eau sont
tous toute la planète est actuellement
on a la série la turquie mais j'étais
très
surprise de constater d'apprendre que le
yémen en 2015 faisait part avant la
guerre avant la guerre du feu faisait
partie des pays qui étaient qui devaient
disparaître
pour des questions de manque d'eau donc
vous voyez que c'est pas
je crois qu'il y aura pas mal de
conflits encore s'il n'y a pas des sur
le plan international une prise de
conscience générale du problème une
question l'accès à l'eau qui nécessite
une régulation internationale gauthier
c'est tout le problème on sait très bien
depuis longtemps que ce facteur ce point
cet élément au étant une des pierres
d'achoppement très sensibles du conflit
israélo-palestinien par exemple mais
dans ce cas là oui vous marie roger
souligné même mohamed morsi qui était
élu président en cours président
islamiste de l'egypte avait un temps
envisagé de bombarder les travaux du
barrage l'éthiopien alors le problème de
fond c'est effectivement qu'il y à ses
besoins en nous mais qu'il y à aussi et
vous allez me pardonner de revenir à ma
marotte mais il ya les nationalismes qui
sont là qu'il soit égyptiens qu'ils
soient soudanais qu'il soit éthiopien
encore une fois on se coltine ce type de
rivalité qui évite par exemple que l'on
fasse une étude sur le partage des eaux
mais aussi sur les conséquences sociales
que ce barrage peut avoir dans tel ou
tel autre pays ça ça n'a pas été fait si
vous ajoutez thion prenez le
nationalisme et le réchauffement
climatique qui forcément va faire bouger
ne serait-ce que les prédictions
climatologique à tel ou tel endroit eh
bien vous avez là deux facteurs qui ne
font qu'aggraver la situation est
effectivement vous avez à juste titre le
droit de dire que ça peut favoriser des
conflits mais encore une fois le conflit
ne part pas de rien et on peut penser
que s'il n'y avait pas ces facteurs qui
sont le nationalisme et le réchauffement
climatique mondial c'est déjà beaucoup
mais on pourrait parvenir un partage
intelligent des ressources merci gucci
et mercier également avoue marie roger
biloa c'était on va plus loin on se
retrouve nous dans quatre minutes pour
un nouveau journal dans pareil cas
[Musique]